ARE YOU READY
GLOBAL CRISIS?STOPHER EBORR
DIRERSITAI
RII DIRE CY NG AUT
CONCURNGE
IC RISOF THE NEW FCRIME HACAN UE
9/11N E ESCALAONCYBE MORPERVASIS
BECOME MORE MOBLE
L THEY PAY WHOE Y RSBUSINESSD SO
RANSOM.
IC ACCELERG THE A L ECONOMY INGE
EXTENTF  PMWARCKS TRIPLEYELLDO
MUCH O REMAINS UNREPORTEMANY COI
BAD PUBLICITY AND FUTURE ATTACKS
SERSECURITY
ONE CEWOLY OTO OMWARE ARE TH THL
ORGANIZATION, IC IF RANCE.
TIS
TA THEIR END
OF THEGABUNT
BLTHESANERE LA.Y CYBEIMAL
BLE.CC TECHNOLLL SOLVES SOME PR
CRL.
AL TRANSITIONAL  AND SELL ON TH
FINAL  NES OE REPLAC
BUT SECRET AND LGECRYPTOCURRENCO
SOMEG SIMILADIS NOT A MATTER
IVMENT, SE
N NTA HOTEL
IN WUT  KNO.
THERE ARE PL O THAT TO .D CREDIT
PEOPLE INVOLVED ARE SE FINANCIA.
BOUT THE
RECOVERYMECK ANDTCOINSAI
COLONI PRECENTMWARE ATTACK THAT
ELUPTOH
TOAVE GENARYENSIE
THE IRS CHIEF HACONGRESS
TO GTYO N ON
CRYPTOCURRENCY TRANSACS OVER
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD STARTPUTHE
ACCOIVIN
. OF CRYPTODENT ADVOCAT THE
WAY OFHE
RALIZED AND MOA
E EN
REQUIRES THAT IT
BITCOIN IS REALLY OU STAY STRONL
IS IOP